hello friend and welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes countdown funny thing when it
comes to video game movies most of them
are rotten on the Tomato Meter even
though we the fans love them so just
keep that in mind as we count down the
best video game movies because half of
them are rotten sorry okay it's time to
press that start button cause here we go
number 10 monster hunter
so this film is based on a role-playing
game that first graced our ps2s in 2004
not the weird role play that your
parents did back in the day this one
Stars Mila Jovovich as Artemis and what
I love about it is that this was
actually Mila's fifth time working with
writer director Paul W S Anderson who
also happens to be her husband but
really nothing says romance like pinning
your wife off against Monsters like this
foreign
so Monster Hunter came out in theaters
in December of 2020 during the pandemic
so suffice to say it didn't really fare
well at the box office or with critics
it's sitting at a rotten 45 with a
critics consensus that says it's held
together by the slenderest threads of
dialogue and plot and exactly what many
viewers will be looking for I mean
slender swords of dialogue is kind of
what I look for in an Uber driver not a
movie but I digress
number nine Mortal Kombat 1995.
okay so the cast for this one could have
looked much more familiar in retrospect
considering that Cameron Diaz was
actually originally cast as Sonya Blade
she was new at the time and she had only
shot the mask with Jim Carrey but the
producer saw dailies of that and
actually decided to cast her but she
ended up having to back out when she got
injured during martial arts training
immediately after she got the role plus
Jean-Claude Van Damme was offered the
role of Johnny Cage but he opted out to
make the game inspired movie Street
Fighter instead which didn't make it
onto this list by the way and that one's
sitting at 11 on the Tomato Meter BT
dubs but what this movie did have was
all of our favorite characters from what
was a pretty big game back in the day
and was the inspiration for my favorite
SNL skit with Tiffany haddish Booboo
Jeffries if you haven't seen it you must
I mean it's almost as good as seeing
Sub-Zero take on Scorpion in live action
finish him
Scorpion and Sub-Zero
deadliest of enemies
but slaves and my power
number eight Rampage
so Rampage was directed by Brad Peyton
and stars The Rock in his second video
game movie after 2005's Doom this one is
based on a 1986 classic game and it
includes plenty of references to the
arcade favorite like George the gorilla
and his friends completely ripping apart
a city for instance which I can confirm
is way more intense when it's not in a
16-bit arcade game
give me these things out
[Music]
the film did well at the worldwide box
office but it holds a Rotten Tomato
Meter score of 51 the consensus from
Critics on this one is that the movie's
sheer butt and mashing abandon might
satisfy audiences in the mood for a
brainless Blockbuster I mean I basically
Button Mash my way through brainless
Blockbusters with my remote control from
home and it's kind of fun not gonna lie
number 7 Tomb Raider 2018. 17 years
after the first film adaptation this one
Stars Alicia vikander as the iconic
Laura Croft now Alicia was a fan of the
video games growing up and she wanted to
make it as realistic as possible so she
put on 12 pounds of muscle and actually
did a bunch of her own stunts the movie
grows 274 million dollars worldwide the
same as the 2001 film although this time
around it actually needed to gross at
least
275 million to break even and
coincidentally that is what I need to
break even from all the movies I go see
you just lost your tip
you just lose your tongue
tongue
number six Mortal Kombat 2021 now this
reboot of the previously attempted film
series follows a washed up MMA fighter
played by Lewis tan and among those
joining him in the cast was Max Wang a
former member of the Jackie Chan stunt
team who would actually pitch ideas on
set to help improve the film's fight
choreography which I gotta say is pretty
cool and it was pretty fun to watch
foreign
[Music]
Ty
speaking of all the fighting though
after an initial NC-17 rating several
gory fight scenes were edited down to
fit under an R rating and while that may
or may not make fans of the game a
little sad the critics didn't seem to
mind with a consensus that says this
installment revives the franchise in
appropriately violent fashion I mean I
guess they really finished him this time
around
number five Sonic the Hedgehog and it
all of a sudden smells better in here
because Sonic the Hedgehog happens to be
the first fresh film on the list but
going back for a sec talks of a Sonic
movie actually began not long after the
video game First Grace to Sega Genesis
in 1991. and by the way if you just got
sudden flashbacks of blowing into the
Sega gaming console it's probably time
for an eye cream anyway fast forward
nearly 30 years when the first trailer
for this movie was finally released in
2019 and I'm sure you all remember where
you were when major backlash broke out
over the way Sonic looked but for the
first time in the history of Hollywood
the power Zippy actually heard what fans
were saying and made some changes now if
only my local burger shop would take
note turns out it worked Sonic set the
record for the biggest opening weekend
for a video game movie in North America
at the time and honestly I feel like it
just made us love Jim Carrey all over
again
that's not good
Sonic I know you got the super speed and
everything but Maddie and I totally
defenseless probably gonna get blown up
pretty much yeah
don't worry I know exactly what to do
foreign
I was not expecting that
but I was expecting not to expect
something so it doesn't count
[Music]
number four Pokemon detective Pikachu
Ryan Reynolds stars as the voice and
facial motion capture of detective
Pikachu in this one which was actually
the first ever live-action Pokemon film
and first live-action movie based on a
Nintendo game since 93's Super Mario
Bros which you honestly can't even try
and forget even if you wanted to and
they picked a good title to release as
this one became the second highest
grossing video game movie ever at the
time I kind of feel like we should be
playing party horns as I read off these
stats because this film also happened to
manage to pull off the impossible and it
made Ryan Reynolds even more lovable in
Pikachu form
pipe yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving he's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm Badcock you're a good cop
oh God that's a very hard one oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah Mr mime has the ability
to make invisible walls ah yes I know I
happen to be a Pokemon too remember
number three Sonic the Hedgehog 2.
so this sequel marked the third time in
his career that Jim Carrey reprized the
same character after Ace Ventura and
Lloyd Christmas perhaps you have heard
of them I low-key wish that he would
just come back as the mask I mean the
guy just looks so good in green
okay
so the cast on this one also includes
Idris Elba as the voice of Knuckles a
role that he actually happened to NAB
after Jason Momoa had to turn it down
and the movie's plot is based on the
game's Sonic 2 and 3 from the early 90s
where Dr Robotnik tricks Knuckles into
going against Sonic and Tails but of
course the child deep inside of you
already knew that and if you want that
Emerald you're gonna have to go through
me
[Music]
number two The Angry Birds movie 2. so
after making the jump from our phones to
theaters with a movie in 2016 this
sequel picks up three years after the
events of the first one and if you
didn't see the first one all you need to
know is the birds are still pretty angry
in this one now it was kind of nice that
we all got to give our hands a break and
enjoy this one on the big screen and the
All-Star voice cast made this movie so
good
[Music]
we've reached 65 miles per hour 15
seconds
let's do this
Leonard it's now or never oh no
that's it
[Music]
even though Angry Birds 2 made a little
less than the first movie at the box
office it did however receive much more
favorable reviews with critics and fans
and it's actually considered an
improvement which is a rarity for a
sequel and honestly birds in general I
feel like I meet people every day that
just don't like birds
number one werewolves Within
and coming in Harry at number one is
werewolves within so this comedy horror
flick is based on the VR game of the
same name but while the game is set in a
medieval village the film is actually
set in modern day I don't know about you
but I would have preferred people
walking around with turkey legs I'm just
kidding my dad jokes are getting really
bad today this one Stars Moana vintrube
who you may or may not recognize from
the ATT commercials and the hilarious
Sam Richardson who is just absolutely
perfect for the part I think we can all
agree that it's unsafe outside and
there's safety in numbers so maybe we
stay here tonight
with you yeah I don't want to go out and
get eight same and then you got room you
can put us all up can't you no it's just
people would have to double up well I
mean
think that'd be fine
all right Cecily okay slow down uh out
of curiosity who is packing I am yes sir
America
wow I have Dave's hunting rifle if that
would be helpful and it's crazy to think
that after all the big names that we've
mentioned on this list today this is the
film that features a second time
director first time writer and a
lesser-known cast and it's still the
highest rated film based on a video game
ever on Rotten Tomatoes as of March
2023. mic drop power to the people
turkey legs for everyone okay friends
I'm starting to make myself hungry so
there it is our list of the best video
game movies and the best thing is your
hands aren't even tired from button
mashing after watching this but do
report back if you end up trying it with
your remote control at home until next
time I'm your host Naz Perez and we'll
see you back here for more top tens on
the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
thank you